Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, this is a shout out to your men. This is a call if you are
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我要向男士们致敬。如果你是
men, if you have ever worked with a man, if you know a man, if you work in a team with a man, this is a call if you have a father, if you are a father, if you have sons. This is a quest, a call, a movement into action to better include men within mental health services and I am joined by a consultant psychiatrist as we talk about how to better engage men and be the difference that makes the difference for men in mental health to make life feel like it's worth living. Hope you'll find it so useful. Please do share this content far and wide. your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a
男士，如果你曾与男士共事，如果你认识男士，如果你在团队中与男士合作，如果你有父亲，如果你是父亲，如果你有儿子，那么请听好了。这是一项使命，一个呼吁，一场行动，旨在更好地将男性纳入心理健康服务体系。今天我邀请了一位精神科顾问医生，我们将探讨如何更好地吸引男性参与，并成为心理健康领域中那个带来改变的关键，让生活变得值得过。希望你会觉得这很有用。请广泛分享这些内容。这是你的指南。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安·特伦特博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。你好，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一位
qualified clinical psychologist. I like to introduce you to interesting themes and debates in psychology and today's is going to be a really powerful episode. I am joined by a consultant psychiatrist today, which is a little bit different, but I hope that whatever discipline you are as you listen to this, and you may not work in mental health at all, you might actually be someone that might find the content in this podcast really empowering and maybe just life changing. We are talking about all things male. How can we better engage men in mental health services? How can we de-shame? How can we have better results and give more hope? It was such a pleasure to speak to my guest today. And I hope that you find it to be just the most nourishing, interesting, thought-provoking
合格的临床心理学家。我喜欢向大家介绍心理学中一些有趣的主题和辩论，今天这一期节目将会非常有影响力。今天我邀请了一位精神科顾问医生，这有点不同，但我希望无论你是什么学科背景，甚至你根本不在心理健康领域工作，你都可能从这期播客的内容中获得力量，甚至改变人生。我们正在讨论关于男性的一切。我们如何能更好地让男性参与到心理健康服务中？我们如何消除羞耻感？我们如何获得更好的结果并给予更多希望？今天能与我的嘉宾交谈真是太荣幸了。我希望你能像我一样，觉得这期节目
episode like I did. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. It is my absolute pleasure to welcome to the podcast today Dr. T. Ayodele Adjaye. Hi. Good. Hi, Harm. It's nice to be here and thank you for having me on the podcast oh thank you for saying yes we um crossed paths on linkedin i think originally you'd started commenting on some of my four minute clinics and then i started commenting on your stuff and then it just got to the stage where we're having big long conversations in the chat and i was like maybe we should actually have a podcast episode to discuss this yeah yeah so it's um it's it's amazing how many um connections you make on on linkedin or particularly i particularly like linkedin because of the professional conversations and it's really a very interesting place where people have regard
既充实、有趣又发人深省。我很期待在节目之后与你交流。今天我非常荣幸地欢迎 T. 阿约德勒·阿贾耶（T. Ayodele Adjaye）博士来到播客。你好。你好，Harm。很高兴来到这里，谢谢你邀请我参加播客。哦，谢谢你答应邀请。我们是在领英（LinkedIn）上结识的，我想最初是你开始评论我的一些“四分钟诊所”视频，然后我开始评论你的内容，后来我们就在聊天中进行了深入的交流，我就想，也许我们应该录一期播客来讨论这个话题。是的，在领英上建立的联系真是太神奇了，我特别喜欢领英，因为那里的专业对话很多，而且这是一个非常有趣的地方，人们彼此尊重，
for each other so it's my i i it's one of my preferred social media platforms for that reason. Me too. I just, I do love the random chats you can have, but I love that you so effortlessly rub up against different disciplines. So you, for example, are a psychiatrist and I love seeing where we might have shared ground, where we might be able to learn things about each other's profession and, you know, potentially what you can do together, together such as this could you tell us a little bit about yourself please right so um i'm a consultant psychiatrist and i work in the southeast of england i'm in the east of kent and um i've been in psychiatry i started my psychiatry training about 23 years ago. Also, I do
所以我非常喜欢这个社交媒体平台。我也是。我确实喜欢那种随意的聊天，但我更喜欢你能够毫不费力地跨越不同学科。例如，你是一位精神科医生，我喜欢看到我们可能拥有的共同点，我们如何能够了解彼此的专业，以及我们未来可能共同做些什么。你能简单介绍一下你自己吗？好的，我是一位精神科顾问医生，我在英格兰东南部工作，在肯特郡东部。我从事精神病学工作，大约 23 年前开始了我的精神病学培训。此外，我还
run a Tripad Care Emotional Wellbeing Hub, which is an online safe, sensitive space for people of Black ethnic minority and faith communities to come together and look at mental
经营着一个 Tripad Care 情感健康中心，这是一个在线的安全、敏感的空间，供黑人、少数族裔和信仰社区的人们聚在一起，以一种非威胁性的方式审视心理
health in a way that is non-threatening and in a way where we can encourage open conversations and sort of normalize things that it's okay not to be okay and to have these conversations in a healthy way yeah such important conversations to have and we're recording this in November and this is likely to be going out in January but I really like the stuff that you were talking um during men's mental health awareness um campaigns in November about about kind of wanting to encourage men specifically to talk and to de-shame the process of having feelings, you know, because we are human.
健康，并鼓励开放的对话，让人们意识到“感觉不好也没关系”，并以健康的方式进行这些对话。是的，这些对话非常重要。我们是在 11 月录制的，这期节目可能会在 1 月播出，但我真的很喜欢你在 11 月“男性心理健康意识月”期间谈论的内容，关于鼓励男性开口说话，消除表达情感的羞耻感，因为我们毕竟是人类。
It's such important stuff to do. Absolutely. Yeah. I couldn't agree with you more. My interaction with men over, I think, more intensively over the last three years, I've shown that it's not that stereotype is actually a stereotype that men don't talk about their emotions. I found it not to be true. What I'm finding is that men actually, like women, like everyone else, have emotions. But we feel we only let down our guts when we feel safe. And I think it's really the honors is on society to begin to challenge those stereotypes about men don't talk.
这确实是非常重要的事情。绝对是。我完全同意。在过去三年里，我与男性的互动更加频繁，这让我发现，所谓的“男性不谈论情感”其实是一个刻板印象。我发现事实并非如此。我发现男性其实和女性一样，和所有人一样，都有情感。但我们只有在感到安全时才会放下防备。我认为社会有责任去挑战那些关于“男性不谈论情感”的刻板印象。
Because it's very difficult to beat stereotypes, isn't it? You feel boxed in. And when you are the outlier, it feels like swimming against the tide. So if society believes that men should not express emotions, it's not okay, it's a sign of weakness. For you to then be the man who comes forward and begins to talk emotions can be quite daunting and that's what I'm hearing from men really which is interesting. It really is and I am the mother of two young boys but I also have an older brother he's 17 months older than me so not massively older but it's interesting for me to be able to kind of compare
因为打破刻板印象非常困难，不是吗？你会感到被束缚。当你成为那个异类时，感觉就像逆水行舟。如果社会认为男性不应该表达情感，认为那是软弱的表现，那么对于一个想要站出来表达情感的男性来说，这可能会非常令人生畏。这就是我从男性那里听到的，非常有趣。确实如此。我本身是两个小男孩的母亲，但我还有一个比我大 17 个月的哥哥，虽然大得不多，但作为妹妹和两个男孩的母亲，同时又是一名心理学家，能够对比
and contrast the differences that I've observed from being the sister of a brother and then being the mother of two boys whilst also being a psychologist absolutely we are empowering our young men these days to to talk about emotions to tap into their feelings. But this is not easy, I think, certainly for our generation, because it wasn't the way that we've been schooled. We're almost having to learn with them as well. Has that been your experiences too? Absolutely. I couldn't agree more that there's such a generational gap in terms of emotions and in terms of men being in touch with emotions. I think the older generation, the baby boomers, don't even do emotions at all. And interestingly, that's striking because it's striking because the suicide figures, for instance, three out of four men dying by suicide in the UK and the highest age group is the 50 to 59 among men.
和观察其中的差异，对我来说非常有趣。当然，我们现在正在赋能我们的年轻男性去谈论情感，去触及他们的感受。但我认为这对我们这一代人来说并不容易，因为我们受到的教育并非如此。我们几乎是在和他们一起学习。你的经历也是这样吗？绝对是。我完全同意在情感方面存在巨大的代沟，在男性与情感接触方面也是如此。我认为老一辈，即婴儿潮一代，根本不谈论情感。有趣的是，这很令人震惊，因为自杀数据表明，在英国，每四名自杀者中就有三名是男性，而男性中自杀率最高的年龄段是 50 到 59 岁。
So that's telling us something, isn't it, about really what's the link between how we feel comfortable about speaking about our emotions and then taking it out on ourselves and then ending up taking our lives. It's just something to think about um yeah i absolutely agree with you i do hope that we are experiencing a bit of a wave of change though for example i don't know if you saw my post on linkedin the other day about what if we were all as emotionally sophisticated as the average modern
所以这告诉了我们一些事情，关于我们对谈论情感的舒适度，以及这如何导致我们伤害自己并最终结束生命。这确实值得深思。是的，我完全同意你的观点。但我确实希望我们正在经历一波变革。例如，不知道你有没有看到我前几天在领英上发的帖子，关于“如果我们都像现代普通七岁孩子那样具备情感成熟度会怎样？”
seven-year-old so as I was on my way home from school with my seven-year-old he started telling me about someone in his class that was basically trying to get him to be her boyfriend and he didn't want that he didn't want that and she was kind of trying to manipulate him and saying well I'll invite you to my party if you if you'll come if you'll just be my boyfriend for a day you know I'll I'll invite you to my party and in the end he basically called her out for gaslighting you know and said I don't I you know this is not okay you can't do this to me I've said no I've you know and and then was able to not only do that in the moment, but then tell me about it as well. And I'm like, gosh, I think there's change happening.
那天我从学校接我七岁的儿子回家，他开始告诉我班上有一个女孩基本上在试图让他做她的男朋友，但他不想，他不想。她试图操纵他，说：“如果你做我一天的男朋友，我就邀请你参加我的派对。”最后，他基本上指出了她的煤气灯效应（gaslighting），说：“我不，这不对，你不能这样对我，我已经拒绝了。”他不仅在当时做到了这一点，后来还告诉了我。我当时想，天哪，我认为变革正在发生。
I think your voice is certainly ahead of the curve. It's probably because it's got the benefit of having been like that, having the benefit of a clinical psychologist mom, all these growing years for the last seven years, which are very crucial years. But I also do agree that I think things are changing. I think my feeling is that the Gen Z's
我认为你的声音肯定走在了时代前沿。这可能是因为他有幸拥有一个临床心理学家妈妈，在过去七年里，这些非常关键的成长岁月里一直受到这种影响。但我确实也认为事情正在改变。我的感觉是，Z 世代
and the millennials young men are more open to discuss their emotions, but they're also looking for safety. I've found that that psychological safety, for better use of a word, in terms of just really having that safe, sensitive space where men don't feel they're going to be criticized or that they're going to be fixed, because that's the other thing. A man by nature wants to feel that they are the king of their castles even when the
和千禧一代的年轻男性更愿意讨论他们的情感，但他们也在寻找安全感。我发现那种心理安全感，如果换个词的话，就是那种真正安全、敏感的空间，让男性觉得他们不会被批评，也不会被“修复”，因为那是另一回事。男性天生想要感觉自己是城堡之王，即使
castle is in ruin and when everything is not where it should be, every man still wants to feel like he is in charge and because men have fixed us what we then have with men relationship, peer relationship with men is that as soon as you open
城堡已经破败，即使一切都不如意，每个男人仍然希望感觉自己掌控一切。因为男性习惯于“修复”我们，所以当我们与男性建立同伴关系时，一旦你开口，对方就想跳出来告诉你哪里做错了，你需要修复什么。而那个男人只是在寻找一个出口，他不是在寻找别人来解决他的问题。他知道自己有麻烦，他知道有些事情需要做，但他只是想要另一个善于倾听且真诚的同伴。好的，那么创造这种安全空间的关键要素之一就是少说多听，而不是一定要去修复。是的，绝对。我们可能会建议一些事情或提出一些想法。但我猜，你相信一个人有能力找到通往治愈的道路吗？
your mouth the other man wants to jump in and tell you the things that you are doing wrong and what you need to fix and and that man is just looking for an outlet he's not looking for somebody to fix his problems he knows that he's in trouble he knows that there are things that need to be done but you also just wants another peer who is a good listener and who is authentic okay so one of the key ingredients then for creating that safe space is a little bit less talking a bit more zipping it's just kind of to hear rather necessarily than to fix. Yeah, absolutely. And there might be, you know, things we can suggest or come up with. But I guess, you know, do you believe in someone's ability to kind of find their way to healing?
你对此有什么看法？我相信我们通往康复之旅的路径各不相同，每个人的康复之旅都是独特的。这可能基于他们的童年经历、教育和他们所接触的事物，以及他们在生活中所经历的一切。因为当面临冲突或挑战时，他们就是从这些地方汲取资源。
What's your opinion of that? So I believe that there are different paths that we find to our recovery journey, that our recovery journeys are different. Everyone's recovery journey is unique. It's based on probably their childhood experiences, their education, and their exposure, the things that they've been exposed to in the course of their lives. Because that's where they pull resources from when it comes to periods of conflict, when it comes to periods of challenges.
所以，我相信每个人都是独特的，旅程也是独特的。我认为，即使作为精神科医生、心理学家、治疗师，我们的角色也是创造一个安全空间，有时对于教练和导师来说也是如此，创造一个安全的地方让人们可以反思。因为有时我们生活在一个忙碌的世界里，所以人们可以退后一步，反思并找到自己的答案，将自己的点滴串联起来。
It's from those places that they draw their resources. So I believe that everyone's unique and journey is unique. And that really, even as psychiatrists, as psychologists, as therapists, I think our role is to create a safe space, sometimes even for coaches and mentors as well, to create a place of safety where people can reflect because sometimes we lead the reality that we live in a busy world. So people can step back and reflect and find their own answers and join their own dots.
是的。当你说话时，我一直在想与督导建立良好关系的重要性，因为实际上，管理我们所做工作的关键部分就是那个安全空间。如果你曾经有过被一个与你不够契合的人督导的经历，那真的会让你动摇。它感觉不安全，让你觉得自己在被评判、被批评，觉得你不够好。而那种安全空间，即使在专业治疗层面，也具有真正的包容性。所以，能够为我们的孩子、我们的服务对象和客户创造这种空间是不可思议的。
Yeah. And, you know know as you were talking it was making me think about the importance of having a really good relationship with your supervisor because actually a key part of managing this work we do is that safe space you know that if you've ever had the experience of being supervised by someone you don't have a good attunement with but it it can really wobble you it doesn't feel safe it makes it feel like you're being judged and you're being criticized that you're not good enough whereas there's something really containing about that safe space even therapeutically with as a professional and so to be able to create that um for our children and create that for our service users and our clients is incredible.
你知道，我们可能是在第一次这样做，特别是如果我们与有复杂创伤背景的人一起工作时。这是一个在任何阶段——无论是客户、同事还是家庭系统——把事情做对的机会。是的，我认为心理安全感和那种包容性，那种空间，怎么强调都不为过。因为当人们感到安全时，所展现出的内容和互动是惊人的。正如你所说，我不认为只有督导者受益，督导者也从这种互动中受益，因为它帮助你感到安全，从而有时也能承认你自己的脆弱，
You know, we might be doing that for the first time ever, especially if we work with people that have had complex trauma backgrounds. You know, it's a chance to get it right at whatever stage we're working with, either a client, a colleague, or, you know, a family system yeah yeah yeah i think psychological safety and i've been containing having that containment that that's um that space is it cannot be overemphasized as you say because it's amazing as well what then comes out the content, the interaction that takes place when people feel safe. Because as you say, I don't even think it's only the supervisor that benefits. I think the supervisor as well benefits from that interaction because it helps you to feel safe to also admit sometimes your own vulnerabilities
因为这是另一个问题，即真正能够承认：是的，我是督导，但我不是所有知识的拥有者，或者有些事情我也在经历。这是一个对我来说也是有机的过程。是的，我不知道你是否做过那个练习，我不会要求你回答这个问题，但请你在心中保持连接，连接到你最感到羞耻的事情。我不会问你答案，但如果你花一点时间去思考那是什么，然后想象必须告诉我，我不会让你这么做。但是，能够做到这一点，以及你想象时可能会感受到的身体感觉，你可能会感到局促不安，可能会开始出汗，可能会开始想：“哦，不，她会怎么看我？这太糟糕了，这会被到处广播。”那种羞耻感、评判和批评，
because that's the other issue in terms of really being able to admit that yes I'm supervisor but I'm not the reporter of all knowledge or that there are things that I'm also going through their processes that it's an organic process for me as well. Yeah I don't know if you've ever done that exercise, and I'm not going to ask you to give me the answer to this question, but for you to hold in mind where you connect now to the thing that you are most ashamed of. And I'm not going to ask you the answer, but if you just take a moment to just think about what that is and then you imagine having to tell me it, I'm not going to do it. But, you know, being able to do that and, you know, the physical sensations that you might feel as you were to imagine that, you know, you might feel squirming. You might start to sweat. You might start to think, oh, no, what's she going to think of me? This is going to be awful. It's going to be broadcast everywhere. It's that sense of shame, judgment criticism um and how it can kind of really
会启动我们的“战斗或逃跑”反应。这本质上就是我们要求客户在每次新评估时所做的事情，不是吗？告诉一个陌生人你内心最深处、最黑暗的想法和感受。但话虽如此，当处理得当时，它并没有你想象的那么糟糕，对吧？是的，我真的很喜欢你如此生动地描述它，因为它让它变得清晰。有趣的是，当处理得当时，我参加过很多咨询，特别是在我学习如何做和如何不做之后。我参加过很多次咨询，有人说：“其实，我刚才对你说了我一生中从未对任何人说过的话。”有时是一个 63 岁的男人，有时是一个 54 岁的男人。
kickstart our fight and flight and that is what we're essentially asking our clients to do certainly every new assessment aren't we you know tell a stranger your deepest darkest thoughts and feelings but that said it's not as bad as you imagine when it's done when it's handled well is it yes that that's really i like the way you've discovered described it so graphically because it just brings it to light and the interesting thing is when it's done well it's amazing how many consultations that um i been in, particularly as I progress and learning the way not to do it and the way to do it. It's amazing how many times I've been in consultations where somebody has said, actually, I've just said to you something that I've never said to anyone else in my whole life. Sometimes it's from a 63-year-old man. Sometimes it's from a 54-year-old man.
所以，这让我很震惊。我在想，哦，哇。所以对于一个 63 岁的男人来说，他可能在过去 55 年里一直意识到自己的想法和幸福感，但他一直带着它。这告诉我，
So, and we are thinking, and that strikes me. I'm thinking, oh, wow. So for maybe 63-year-old man, so he's been conscious about his thoughts and about his wellbeing, maybe for the last 55 years, and he's been carrying that around. And it just, I think, it tells me
我们能创造多少安全感，以及通过正确的方式，它如何能触发或启动某人的康复过程。有时人们不参与是因为他们担心会发现什么。人们不想去精神科咨询。他们认为被转诊到精神科几乎就像被判了死刑。因为对未知的恐惧，
how much of the safety we can create and how it can trigger somebody's set up or initiate somebody's recovery process by doing it right. And sometimes people don't engage because they are worried about what they're going to find. People don't want to come to psychiatric consultations. They think it's almost like a death sentence being referred to a psychiatrist. And because of the fear of the unknown,
人们不参与。当然，随之而来的结果是，由于干预延迟，结果往往更糟。是的，成为其中的一部分是如此强大且荣幸的事情，不是吗？能够成为那个带来改变的关键，并在事情恶化之前尽早介入。所以，男性在产后期间往往会非常棘手，在第一次成为父亲后，也许他们目睹了
people don't engage. And of course, what then happens, sadly, is that outcomes are worse because of poor, because of the delayed intervention. Yeah, such incredibly powerful and privileged stuff to be part of, isn't it? And to be potentially the difference that makes the difference and to get in there early enough before things spiral. So quite often during a postnatal period actually for men can be really tricky after they've become a father for the first time perhaps they've you know witnessed
创伤性的分娩，也许他们担心伴侣和孩子的生命，然后他们为此挣扎了多年。然后当孩子 15、18、20 岁时遇到我，我们再处理那个影响了他们育儿能力、甚至影响了他们祖辈能力、影响了他们生活的出生创伤。如果我们能早点见到他们，那对他们来说将是一种解脱。所以我完全赞同你关于“现在就做”的观点。因为很多人曾对我说：“哦，我真希望我早点这样做。”因为实际上，在鼓励任何感到自己处于那个临界点的人时，现在就做吧。
a traumatic birth perhaps they're worried for the life of their partner and their child and then they've struggled with that for years and years and years and then kind of meet me when the child's 15 18 20 whatever and we're then processing that birth trauma that's impacted on their ability to parent it might have impacted on their ability to grandparent you know to run their lives and had we been able to see them at a sooner period it would have just been liberating for them and so I absolutely echo what you say about do it now, you know, do it now. Because so many times people have said to me, oh, oh, well, I wish I had done this sooner. Because actually, you know, it wasn't as bad as in terms of really encouraging anyone who feels that they're at that point in which they're contemplating to just do it now.
因为我一直听到同样的信息，人们说：“好吧，其实我真希望我早点做。”它并没有我预期的那么具有威胁性。而且，我没想到它会是一个如此有益的过程，因为我曾经害怕进行这些接触，但几次疗程后，我开始期待它，因为我真的能感觉到事情正在改变，朝着正确的方向发展。所以，“现在就做”是我会向任何正在考虑的人传达的信息。你知道，我认为现在关于心理健康支持、治疗和干预，有什么信息变得无益了吗？我最近经常听到人们对我说：“好吧，我知道在和你一起工作时，情况会先变糟再变好。”人们说：“我没做，因为我负担不起让情况
Because that same message is what I hear all the time when people say, well, actually, I wish I'd done it sooner. It's not as threatening as I expected it to be. But also, I didn't expect that it was going to be such a beneficial process in terms of really the the it's like I dreaded coming um having these encounters but now I'm looking forward to it after a few sessions because I can actually feel that things are changing and moving in the right direction so um do it now is is is the same message that I would echo to anyone who is contemplating. And do you know what message I think is now becoming unhelpful about mental health support and therapy and intervention? It's one that I've heard lately quite a lot is that people are saying to me, well, I know it's going to get worse before it gets better when I'm working with you. And people are like, I didn't do it because I couldn't afford for it to
变得更糟。”但对我来说，其实如果我们管理得当，在你的容忍范围内帮助你，我们不会做超出你舒适度的事情。所以，如果有人听到这里，心想“我负担不起先变糟再变好”，我不认为这必然会发生。你对此有什么看法？我完全同意，因为我认为专业人士——无论是治疗师、精神科医生、临床心理学家还是心理咨询师——的角色是创造安全感和包容性。我认为我们的责任之一是帮助进入疗程的人能够管理他们可能感受到的任何痛苦。所以，我们的服务的一部分是能够管理这种情况，无论在第一次参加这些疗程时出现什么情况。所以，
get any worse. But for me, it's like, actually, if we're managing you well, and helping you within your window of tolerance, we're not going to do things that are outside of your level of comfortability. So please, if I guess guess if if anyone's listening to this thinking i can't afford for it to get worse before it gets better i don't think that's necessarily what happens what's your view on that i i couldn't agree more because i think that it's important we i think the the role of the professional, be it a therapist, the psychiatrist, the clinical psychologist, or the psychotherapist, is to create that safety and containment. And I think part of our responsibilities is to help the person who is coming into that session to be able to manage some of the distress that they may feel, whatever it is. So part of the offer is to be able to manage the situation, whatever arises in the context of coming to those sessions for the first time. So really,
我完全同意这可能非常有破坏性，因为人们不明白那意味着什么。“先变糟再变好”，这到底要持续多久？某人可能已经在处理反复发作的恐慌症或闪回，他们无法想象情况变糟会是什么样子。所以，这确实是一个应该非常明确说明的信息，而不是仅仅把它当作一句陈词滥调。
I absolutely agree that it can be very damaging because people don't understand what that means. It's going to get worse before it gets better. How long is a piece of string here? And somebody's already probably dealing with recurring panic attacks or having flashbacks. They can't imagine what it's going to be like for things to get worse. So really, that's a message that should be very clearly spelled out rather than just throwing it as a cliche.
“先变糟再变好”。因为当人们进入那个空间时，我们会一直在那里握住他们的手。我觉得这才是我们应该说的。也许我们应该把它改成“情况会变好”。是的，绝对。因为它确实会变好。也许更多情况变好的人，特别是那些有影响力的人、有平台的人、名人、社会榜样，真的需要谈论这样一个事实：是的，它确实会变好。
It's going to get worse before it gets better. Because we are going to be there to hold anyone's hand when they come into that space. That's probably what we should be saying, I feel. Maybe we just change it to it's going to get better. Yeah, absolutely. Because it does get better and perhaps more people who for whom it's got better should really particularly people who have clout people who have a platform people who are celebrities people who are role models in society really need to be talking about the fact that yes it does get better
我给了自己一个机会，我很高兴我这么做了。我认为这也是一个重要的信息。是的，当有人——实际上对我这么说的男性比女性多——当有人说“如果我没遇到你，我就结束自己的生命了”，你知道，现在我对未来有了希望。这是真实的，它发生了，这可以改变人们的生活，然后改变下一代。我喜欢你刚才提到的关于代际的部分，因为我们确实知道，例如，不良童年经历（ACEs），我们倾向于将其延续下去。不良童年经历的影响是代际的。
I took a chance on myself and I'm glad I did I think that's also an important message to put out there yeah and when someone it's more men who do say this to me actually than women when somebody says if I hadn't met you I would have ended my life you know and now i have hope for the future it's it's real it happens it you know this can transform people's lives and then transform the next generation too i like the generational part of what you just mentioned in terms of generation because really we do we do know, for instance, that adverse childhood experiences, that we do tend to carry that over. The impact of adverse childhood experiences is generational.
如果它们没有得到处理，它们就会开始显现，然后变得代际化，因为我们会将那些代际创伤传递给我们的孩子，然后他们又会传递给他们的孩子。所以，这对于那些犹豫不决的男性来说是另一个激励。因为我知道对于大多数男性来说，由于我们承担的责任感，无意中给下一代造成伤害并不是我们许多人想要做的。所以，这可能是另一个理由，让我认为我不仅是为了自己，也是为了我的孩子，为了我的……（注：此处音频中断，推测为“为了我的家庭”）。
That if they're not dealt with, they start showing that it then becomes generational in terms of we will then pass that on those generational trauma onto our own children and then they will pass it on to their own children so really that's another incentive particularly for men who have one drain should i should i not because i know for most men because of the sense of responsibility that we carry passing inflicting um inflicting damage on the next generation inadvertently is not something that a lot of us would want to do. So that could be another reason actually to think that I'm not only doing it for myself, I'm doing it for my children, I'm doing it forvation is that people haven't always had their own male parenting experience.
（接上文）……另一个原因是人们并不总是有自己的男性育儿经验。
And what's been really nice is when there's been males in the community who have kind of stepped up to kind of try to be a positive role model and I think that's really really important um what's your experience of that so that's that's um I totally agree on that count as well that the responsibility of males in in society particularly if one is a male who has managed to go through the rite of passage and you've got some things wrong, but you've also got some things right. And you're now at a place where for one reason or another, most people don't choose to be like that. But for some reason or one reason or another, people then look up to you. I think it's important to then extend the definition of parenting. So beyond biological relationships, I think there's a responsibility on the men who have managed to go through those rites of passage to look out for young people
非常棒的是，社区中有男性挺身而出，试图成为积极的榜样，我认为这非常非常重要。你的经历如何？我完全同意这一点，即男性在社会中的责任，特别是如果你是一个已经走过成人礼的男性，虽然你犯过一些错误，但也做对了一些事情。你现在处于一个位置，由于某种原因，大多数人选择不那样做，但由于某种原因，人们仰望你。我认为重要的是要扩展育儿的定义。所以，超越生物学关系，我认为那些已经走过这些成人礼的男性有责任去照顾社区中那些可能无根的年轻人。
in your community who might be rootless. Rootless in terms of they have no roots because there's no father figure in their lives. That's one thing that the Tripad Care Emotional Wellbeing Hub, for instance, looks out for in terms of quite a lot of young men through that hub that I've been able to connect with some of them that I didn't have one-to-one sessions with in terms of just really helping them to have somebody who who is a grounding factor in their lives and who creates a sense of safety to be able to help them to consider things to reflect and help them to join their own thoughts without being critical and yeah. Such important stuff so tell us
无根，因为他们的生活中没有父亲形象。例如，Tripad Care 情感健康中心关注的就是这一点，通过该中心，我能够与许多年轻人建立联系，其中一些我没有进行一对一的疗程，只是真正帮助他们拥有一个在生活中能起到支撑作用的人，一个创造安全感的人，能够帮助他们思考、反思，并帮助他们将自己的想法串联起来，而不带批判性。是的，太重要了。那么，请告诉我们
a bit more about the tripartite care mind gym how did you come to start putting that together yeah that's that's quite an interesting question and the reason is because it was quite a dramatic way so just talking about the benefits of social media because some people knock social media and say oh it's all rubbish but but there are benefits to social media we benefits of social media, because some people knock social media and say, oh, it's all rubbish. But there are benefits to social media. We met on social media, for instance. So my friend, just about the time we were entering into the second lockdown, was about September 2020. She puts up a post about another story she's heard about
更多关于 Tripad Care Mind Gym 的信息，你是怎么开始把它组织起来的？这是一个非常有趣的问题，原因是因为它是一个非常戏剧性的方式。谈论社交媒体的好处，因为有些人抨击社交媒体，说“哦，那都是垃圾”，但社交媒体确实有好处。我们是在社交媒体上认识的，例如。所以我的朋友，就在我们进入第二次封锁的时候，大约是 2020 年 9 月。她发布了一篇关于她听到的另一个故事的帖子，关于
holding her son from jumping off from a high-rise building. So they lived in a high-rise, and that was really, and I read that and I thought, oh my God, I've always been thinking about doing something for young men, particularly from young men who are from ethnic minority backgrounds, and this might be my opportunity so I sent my name box message and say actually I read your post and it just feels you know sometimes you read something and it just feels like it's all personal you feel that it's almost like destiny is calling my name like you've got to do something now do it now so I sent her a message and said that really strikes me and then she gave me the details and at that point i then thought okay let's put out a i was going to put out a post
阻止她儿子从高层建筑跳下。他们住在高层，我读到那个故事时想，天哪，我一直想为年轻人做点什么，特别是来自少数族裔背景的年轻人，这可能是我的机会。所以我发了私信说，我读了你的帖子，感觉……你知道，有时你读到某样东西，感觉非常个人化，你觉得这几乎就像命运在呼唤我的名字，就像你现在必须做点什么，现在就做。所以我给她发了信息，说这真的触动了我。然后她给了我详细信息，那时我就想，好吧，让我们发布一个……我本来打算发布一个帖子，
and i did i said please inbox me if you're a parent who has a child who is struggling with mental difficulties at the moment or distress let's know um if you are if you would be interested in meeting and that was my opt-out clause. I'm being very transparent here. My thinking was nobody's going to respond anyway, and then I would have satisfied my conscience. I put out the post out there, nobody responded. And I was inundated with inbox messages. So I knew, okay, now you have to do something. And so we had this first zoom meeting February 2021 where people came together and we just said this is an open session and the attendance to start
我也确实发布了。我说：“如果你是一位孩子目前正在经历心理困难或痛苦的家长，请私信我。如果你有兴趣见面，请告诉我。”那是我的退出条款。我在这里非常透明。我的想法是反正没人会回应，然后我就能满足我的良心了。我发布了帖子，没人回应。结果我收到了海量的私信。所以我知道，好吧，现在你必须做点什么。于是我们在 2021 年 2 月举行了第一次 Zoom 会议，人们聚在一起，我们只是说这是一个开放的会议，出席人数……
with Saturday morning I was surprised how many people turned up and the stories so that was when we thought okay yes there is a bed that's in India and that's how it progressed. Great. So it's all online, is it? It's all online. We meet by Zoom and it's usually the last Thursday of the month. And it's usually from 7pm till 9pm. Is this over 18s? Is there an age spread or a range that you can cater for? Very interesting question. Because when the Zoom session started,
周六早上，我很惊讶来了这么多人。那些故事……那就是我们认为“好吧，是的，确实有需求”的时候，事情就是这样发展的。太棒了。所以它完全是在线的，是吗？完全在线。我们通过 Zoom 会面，通常是每个月的最后一个星期四。时间通常是晚上 7 点到 9 点。这是针对 18 岁以上的人吗？有一个年龄跨度或范围吗？非常有趣的问题。因为当 Zoom 会议开始时，
it was targeted at 18 to 35-year-olds. But then I began to get messages from parents who said, oh, you are being ageist here. You should really be catering for the parents as well. So these days, what happens is that there's no age restriction, but we then have the gym courses. The gym courses are targeted. So it's a six weeks course
它是针对 18 到 35 岁人群的。但后来我开始收到家长的信息，他们说：“哦，你在这里有年龄歧视。你也应该照顾家长。”所以现在，没有年龄限制，但我们有“健身课程”（Gym courses）。健身课程是有针对性的。这是一个为期六周的课程，
where we discuss issues of identity. We discuss issues of finding your purpose, having a sense of what am I here for, dealing with issues of depression, stress, anxiety, and all of those. And that's ring-fenced for the 18 to 35-year-olds. And is that 18 to 35 for males, or is that males and females? Males and females.
我们讨论身份问题。我们讨论寻找目标、拥有“我为什么在这里”的感觉、处理抑郁、压力、焦虑等问题。这些是专门为 18 到 35 岁人群设立的。那是针对 18 到 35 岁的男性，还是男女皆可？男女皆可。
Males and females, okay, yeah. Yeah, and, you know, I think, well done, well done. And I know before we started talking, we were talking about actually this going over and above monetary compensation for the work that we do. This is, you know, in your words, this is like a calling. This is because you really care about alleviating distress in people yeah that's that's an interesting conversation wasn't it because i think in order to continue to be a mental professional there must be and to do it well you must sit beyond just something that pays the bills uh there must be a sense of calling a sense of purpose that this is something that i'm caught out to do and and and it's also a privilege it's also a blessing to be able to do it because i feel that when we see the transformation
男女皆可，好的。是的，而且，我认为，做得好，做得好。我知道在我们开始交谈之前，我们谈到了这实际上超越了我们所做工作的金钱补偿。用你的话说，这就像一种使命。这是因为你真的关心减轻人们的痛苦。是的，那是一个有趣的对话，不是吗？因为我认为为了继续成为一名心理健康专业人士，并且做得好，你必须不仅仅是为了支付账单。必须有一种使命感，一种目标感，即这是我被召唤去做的事情。而且，能够做到这一点也是一种特权，一种祝福。因为我觉得当我们看到你雄辩地谈论的转变，
that you've spoken that you've eloquently spoken spoken about the the way people move on in their recovery journey some men confiding in you that if they hadn't met you they would have taken their lives there's no pay packet that can pay for that um i think it's far beyond so there must be a sense of purpose and calling that drives us and keeps us going yeah i definitely agree i definitely agree and i have that i think it's the way i've been raised by my dad who um sadly is no longer with us but he kind of had the the belief that if you can do something for someone then you should and I guess I've probably got some of that in myself as well. I yeah that's my ethos as well that if you if it's a privilege to be able to do to be in that position um i think sometimes because we live in society where sometimes we look at we're almost programmed
人们在康复之旅中前进的方式，一些男性向你吐露，如果没遇到你，他们就会结束生命，没有任何薪水能支付那个。我认为这远远超出了金钱。所以必须有一种目标感和使命感在驱动我们，让我们坚持下去。是的，我绝对同意，我绝对同意。我有这种感觉，我认为这是我父亲抚养我的方式，他很遗憾已经不在了，但他有一种信念：如果你能为某人做点什么，你就应该去做。我想我身上可能也有一些这种特质。是的，这也是我的信条，如果你能处于那个位置，这是一种特权。我认为有时因为我们生活在一个社会中，有时我们被媒体和所有信息编程，
by media and by all the messages to make us look at life in the half full or half empty glass view when we are looking at the things that are going wrong. But if you're in a position to be able to do anything, it's a position of privilege and it's a blessing to be able to do that. And I think that's something that we should all do. We are the ones that benefit at the end of the day. Yeah, definitely.
让我们以“半杯水”的视角看待生活，当我们关注那些出错的事情时。但如果你处于能够做任何事情的位置，那是一个特权的位置，能够做到这一点是一种祝福。我认为这是我们都应该做的。归根结底，受益的是我们自己。是的，绝对。
It's a two-way street isn't it absolutely thank you so much for your time dr j it's been really really lovely speaking with you where can people learn more about you and about the tripart care mind gym right so uh so the tripart care um we've got a YouTube channel actually by the same name, Tripadcare. And we've got lots of videos on there where people can connect. And of course, on LinkedIn, that's where I put most of my thoughts and posts. I'm Dr. Tiara Dele Ajay on LinkedIn. And we've got a website that is still just developing there's not a lot of content there yet but also by the same in tripath care
这是一个双向的过程，不是吗？非常感谢你的时间，Dr. J，和你交谈真是太愉快了。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和 Tripad Care Mind Gym 的信息？好的，Tripad Care 有一个同名的 YouTube 频道，Tripadcare。上面有很多视频，人们可以在那里建立联系。当然，在领英上，那是我发表大部分想法和帖子的地方。我在领英上是 Dr. Tiara Dele Ajay。我们有一个网站，还在开发中，内容还不多，但也是同名的 Tripad Care。
thank you i will make sure that i link in the show notes and with the social posts and stuff so that people can find you easily but honestly it's been a pleasure speaking with you i feel like i could speak to you for for days and still not be done. If you had any advice for reducing burnout in the mental health professional sphere, what would that be? If there was any advice, I think it would be that one to make sure that one avails oneself of supervision, having a peer support group. But importantly, having a life outside of work. I think that sometimes as health professionals,
谢谢，我会确保在节目说明和社交帖子中添加链接，以便人们能轻松找到你。老实说，和你交谈真是太愉快了，我觉得我可以和你聊上几天，而且还聊不完。如果你对减少心理健康专业领域的职业倦怠有什么建议，那会是什么？如果有任何建议，我认为首先要确保利用好督导，拥有一个同伴支持小组。但重要的是，要有工作之外的生活。我认为有时作为健康专业人士，
it's very easy for our job to become a persona and to become our identity. I think having outlets, something where, possibly not even doing it with people who are mental colleagues something that makes you grounded and keeps you in touch with reality is a good thing such brilliant advice um thank you again for your time um and for the important work that you're doing with your clients and with people that you may never meet face-to-face to. Thank you. And thank you for having me on the programme.
我们的工作很容易变成一种人设，变成我们的身份。我认为拥有一些宣泄渠道，做一些事情，甚至可能不是和心理学同事一起做，这能让你脚踏实地，让你与现实保持联系，这是一件好事。真是太棒的建议了，嗯，再次感谢你抽出时间，感谢你为你的客户以及那些你可能从未谋面的人所做的重要工作。谢谢。也谢谢你邀请我参加这个节目。
And thank you on the podcast. And thank you for doing this podcast to put message out there and to highlight, spotlight some of the brilliant things that are going on around. Gosh, speaking to Dr. Ajay was just like soul food. It was really, really lovely. I feel really privileged to have been able to have that conversation. And I hope that you found it useful for whatever reason that you are listening to or watching this, either because you work in mental health, or because you might be male or be looking at trying to help support and better
也谢谢你参加这个播客。感谢你制作这个播客来传播信息，并重点介绍、聚焦周围发生的一些精彩的事情。天哪，与Ajay博士交谈简直就像心灵的食粮。真的非常非常美好。我感到非常荣幸能够进行那次谈话。我希望无论你是因为什么原因在收听或观看这个节目，你都觉得它很有用，无论是你从事心理健康工作，还是你可能是男性，或者正在寻求帮助、支持和改善
understand someone who is male what an incredible job i do what an incredible job he does and please know that there are people like us who work close to you so if you need care and support you need guidance and nurturance there are people out there who can help you who will get you who will hear you and can help make this different for you and those around you i just love what i do and if you love it too please help me spread the word about this podcast i look forward to bringing the next episode to you please do let me know what you think to the episodes. Come and connect with me on my social media. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. I will look forward to hearing what you think. And if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes, please do let me know. And in the meantime, I hope you find the books useful, the Clinical Psychologist Collective, the Aspiring Psychologist
了解身边的男性。我的工作多么令人难以置信，他所做的工作多么令人难以置信。请知道，有像我们这样的人在你身边工作，所以如果你需要关怀和支持，需要指导和培养，外面有人可以帮助你，他们会理解你，倾听你，并能帮助你和你周围的人做出改变。我热爱我的工作，如果你也喜欢它，请帮我传播这个播客。我期待着为你带来下一集。请务必让我知道你对这些剧集的看法。来我的社交媒体上与我联系吧。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。我期待着听到你的想法。如果你对未来的播客剧集有什么想法，请务必告诉我。在此期间，希望你觉得这些书有用，《临床心理学家集体》、《有抱负的心理学家》
Collective, and I will look forward to bringing the next episode of the podcast to you from 6am on Monday. Thanks for being part of my world. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Mary Entrance My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner.
集体，我期待着在周一早上6点为你带来下一集播客。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Dr. Marianne Trent的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习从业者。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，成为一名临床心理学家没有完美的方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。